and then to top this all off my bar
mitzva I was Jewish I'm Jewish I was
like where are you right now
[Laughter]
I was so fat well once again we went
opposite I'm now fatter so I didn't
really care about the religious part so
much but I really cared about the part I
was obsessed with the party and you know
every Bar Mitzvah party had this big
theme and so the theme of mine because I
couldn't decide was Broadway meets pop
music which one gay men laughed in this
audience which is an odd theme what does
that even mean there was a like a life
like a life-size cutout of Madonna on
one side of the DJ booth there are tears
in your eyes right now and on the other
side of the DJ booth and this is non
exaggeration was a life-size cutout of
the Phantom of the Opera that was the
first musical I ever saw I was obsessed
with at the time yeah and all the kids
tables were named after pop stars that I
loved at the time I sat at the Madonna
table there was a George Michael table
Aerosmith for the straight boys and then
all the adult tables were named after
Broadway shows it was rock and roll they
might have been open you never and that
was my crazy childhood I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this